bonjour philippe raud dietsch bonjour
merci beaucoup d'être avec nous en
direct dans la matinale d'ayrté france
je sais que c'est pas simple est-ce que
vous pouvez nous nous préciser pourquoi
cette crainte d'une nouvelle guerre en
bosnie herzégovine aujourd'hui
je dirais pas qu'il ya en ce moment
vraiment une crainte d'une nouvelle
guerre à court terme certainement pas
mais j'ai un terme un peu plus long oui
parce que la question n'est pas vraiment
résolu
les accords de paix de dayton ont été
perçus par toutes les parties comme
une une étape dans dans le
fait uniquement pour terminer la guerre
est achevé une paix qui on était
conscient au moment même de la signature
une paix qui serait assez fragile oui
donc vous dites que les accords de
dayton finalement c'était un
cessez-le-feu mais il y à des élections
l'an prochain pour l'instant rassembler
ces trois communautés restent très
compliquées
oui c'est une situation très compliquée
parce que vous avez trois partis qui
sont assez
opposées l'une à l'autre même si les
croates et les bosniaques musulmans sont
regroupés dans une entité
a eu les côtes ne sont pas vraiment
satisfaits de cette position ils se sont
un peu
discriminée par la majorité musulmane
dont la fédération bosnie herzégovine et
même
leurs représentants dans la présidence
commune l'un des trois
représentants
j'ai un copain qui a été selon le côté
croate élue par les voix des bosniaques
musulmans
finalement est-ce que ces accords de
dayton qui prévoyait notamment des
institutions communes et ce qu'ils ont
réellement fonctionné ou pas tant que ça
depuis depuis presque 26 ans maintenant
pas tant que ça parce que pour achever
un un accord il faut que toutes les
parties soient d'accord avec eux avec
les décisions et ça n'a pas été toujours
le cas une des questions les plus
importantes peut-être était
[Musique]
l'accession
temps et le côté serbe est
opposé à cette idée ou
reconnaissance de la soie dit
indépendance du kosovo également je
voulais dire que l'armée serbe
formation d'une nouvelle armée serbe
s'est pas vraiment la vérité parce que
l'armée serbe était prévoyez par les
accords de dayton et errer père était
incorporée à alarmer unitaire à l'armée
bosniaque il y a dix sept ans et cet
effet sous la pression occidentale mais
il adore dit maintenant veut en fait
réactiver toutes les compétences que
l'entité serbe la république serbe a
selon les accords de détente etc c'est
ça en fait qui repose la haye washington
- le président des serbes de bosnie qui
néanmoins voudrait davantage d'autonomie
ans c'est bien ça
ils nous demandent pas
plus d'autonomie que
l'autonomie qui a été prévoyez par part
l'accord de détente et ses appels pour
l'indépendance de la république serbe
vis-à-vis la bosnie sont en fait une
réaction à cette idée et vous devez vous
devez être conscient qu
il a un argument de plus parce que
la communauté internationale
en fait la communauté occidentale a
toujours favorisé l'indépendance de tous
les autres peuples ex-yougoslaves sauf
le serbe s'était seulement les serbes
qui ne pouvaient pas
avoir le droit à
l'autodétermination et c'est en fait le
cas en république serbe en ce moment et
c'est la carte sur laquelle elle joue un
monsieur douadic beaucoup d'américains
qui est qui qui viennent dans la région
justement par crainte d'un nouveau
conflit que pensez-vous des tractations
américaine en ce moment et les menaces
de sanctions justement contre le
président des serbes de bosnie c'est pas
vraiment une crainte de guerre
franchement parce que c'est pas les
serbes qui menace de guerre c'est plutôt
un autre côté c'est ce que disaient les
occidentaux en tout cas oui c'est ce que
tu veux dans les occidentaux disent que
monsieur john hughes qui était né
ultranationaliste alors c'est pas vrai
du tout il est il est arrivé au pouvoir
comme le chef d'un parti social
démocrate a été
reposée
aaa aux autorités qui ont été menées
pendant la guerre par radovan karadzic
et ensuite par ses successeurs arrivée
de son parti le parti démocrate serbe
les occidentaux même les pressions
américaines en ce moment comment
sont-elles accueilli
très mal parce que les serres de ronde
une
mémoire très mauvaise on vers les cinq
sanctions et qu'on vous mentionner les
sanctions
ça ça décroche un
des mémoires très mauvaise et un
sentiment pas vraiment amicale envers
les ce qui qui qui qui
qui propose des sanctions mais il y a
une
caractéristique serbe qui est qui et
si vous faites de pression on va réagir
à l'opposé de ce que vous voulez
vraiment faire
les serbes ont toujours été un peuple
libertaire mm c'était le seul pays
communiste qui se rencontrent après la
deuxième guerre mondiale a dit non à
staline l'ancienne yougoslavie qui était
majorité composée des serbes et qui n'a
jamais fait partie ni du pacte de
varsovie ni de de l'otan qui voulait
faire son propre propre chemin et on
vous lance à on a été les indés des
organisateurs du mouvement non-alignés
alors les sanctions c'est pas vraiment
une bonne carte à jouer ce sont des
serbes ont en question merci beaucoup
philippe prodige pour votre éclairage ce
matin dans la matinale je le rappelle
vous êtes rédacteur en chef adjoint du
magazine pk tu jeu